clearly all a bunch of potheads made up
all this what is the secret menu
it's basically stuff people made up when
they wait to talk about I assume that
none of these are actually secrets
people were just blacked out when they
first tried them and forgot mine's pink
it's not like cream soda this tastes
like cough medicine there's a lot of
things that taste like cough syrup that
I'm really neat I think this would be a
really good mixer with vodka that's
gonna burn you butthole girl I feel like
this would make a good pillow he's
really hasn't hit me out the more and
more I eat the better it is
I was definitely ordered us this looks
like something that was made in an
easy-bake oven by a five-year-old Oh
Cheers yeah it's basically just nachos
as a pizza which is and I support that I
love nachos I'm trying to get into it
this is gelatin it's not moving when I
shake it oh wow I don't like things that
are totally sugary so I actually like
this a lot
that's a nice sweet and then like salty
taste you know this is like one of those
things that you want to get you think of
when you're high oh you're like oh my
god
ping invented this incredible thing this
is like a baby if nothing else these are
really cheap toys it's just like bacon
of all our tastes my stomach is not
built for this
no one stomach is like like a mother
bird prepared our food for us like a
chewed-up for me and then spit it into a
tortilla
thank you we were on our way to work so
she wrapped it up thank you mother good
thank you oh my god this is uncredible
flavor-wise I'm really really into this
that's that's scary and I honestly like
would rather just have their Doritos on
their own I like the flavor of the
cooler ranch tortilla but maybe bury it
and taco bell's like weird pita
invention like what is this supposed to
be their secret menu was really good
overall I think that this was on par
with most of Taco Bell I already am like
feeling indigestion
I'm already burping whoever came up with
these items is an American Hero